tonight my brand new nationwide
restaurant competition kicks off with
one of the world's favorite cuisines
it's Italian and it promises to be an
incredible battle between two very
different but equally stunning Italian
restaurants
I'm always lovely tell him food and that
is best it really manages transform
simple fresh ingredients into
extraordinary dishes packed full of
flavor I'm doing it please Ashley thank
you
the Italians take their cooking and
ingredients very very seriously
and they're fiercely competitive love
that passion you sent in a huge number
of Italian nominations the two fighting
for a place in the semi-finals of this
nationwide competition are both
exceptional castamere from Bristol
versus minuta from London we're going to
see broad young talent from the West
Country take on a highly experienced
chef in the cafetorium go to war you win
it we're here for the Casa Mia's
cutting-edge Italian food will battle it
out with Meniere's authentic rustic
dishes - ambitious young calorie
alchemist will challenge a Sicilian
gastronomic Godfather if you mess up
you're gonna get it I mean you went in
for the high jump with me the sky's the
limit
you just want to move forward and gets
his hoppity game but who will come out
on top
hopefully you don't mean it mistakes
bring it on it's what we do I got to
push both is he telling contenders the
breaking point with three daunting
challenges I intend to test them to the
absolute limit because they're going to
be one winner the first of my two
brilliant Italian competitors is Manila
a truly exceptional restaurant that
fought its way through thousands of
nominations Manila named after the
Sicilian almond is run by 45 year-old
Santino who cooked healthy authentic
food inspired by the love of his
birthplace Sicily my cooking it is all
about simplicity it's about taking it as
few ingredients as possible and making
sure that the quality of those
ingredients shined
[Applause]
he spent years as a head chef for
someone London's top restaurants before
opening Manila a year ago they quickly
get the low following display screens
since late I mean that man cooks from
the heart
just quit please go Santino is fiery and
passionate demanding nothing less than
perfection from all this kitchen staff
and these front of house managers Angelo
and Rocco if you've messed up you're
gonna get I mean you went in for the hi
job with me
[Music]
very competitive person I go out to
waiting I don't like to lose I'm here
against anybody's in the country no
doubt I love Santino's competitive
spirit and is gonna need every ounce of
it to handle my first pressure test
because my 30 hand-picked guests are
about to arrive and order all at the
same time if every restaurants worst
nightmare
where's last time we did 30 killers
about that we can do this we can do this
okay good I love that level of
confidence your new restaurants
absolutely on the block a lot to prove
so I'll be watching everything I'll be
like a hawk over the dining room Rocco
and here in the kitchen as well
I'm giving Manila just two hours to
produce the best meal these 30 customers
have ever eaten do your customers proud
and more importantly don't let
yourselves down yeah look I got si
Santino's restaurant is packed I'm going
to push the kitchen in the front of
house to the limit and in the process
give them a chance to shine every
service is warped got to wall you win it
that's what we're here for
on the menu tonight is a choice of three
starters sicilian tomato salad hot
smoked venison and
lobster linguine wouldn't lobster
problem a mistake 14 or 16 linguini of
lobster service has only just started
and already I can see a problem he's
gonna be sitting there about five
minutes time because everyone's ordering
linguini and no one's controlling it
check on it takes about a quarter of an
hour to cook each lobster linguine to
cover some awesome Dewey linguine
lobster put the linguine in 13 minutes
linguine
if front-of-house don't persuade the
diners to order the simplest starters
Santina will struggle to finish service
within the two-hour time limit I want
three lobsters 1 2 3 a good maitre d
should be able to sell the other dishes
on the menu post the results oh yes and
baddest linguini push the venison the
venison delicious I'm afraid I'm gonna
have the langoria news
as well so please relieve me of well
guess what
how long for the next four linguini and
to leave with those six linguini after
that and with the clock ticking some
Tina's up against it
Jesus Christ I feel for him right now in
there because he's about to explode it's
like an angry you just pulled the pin
and here we go any minute now guaranteed
why cause he's getting screwed upstairs
they have to help him I'm making his
life a little bit easier than that are
they solid in that delicious venison at
1-1 everyone's gonna but everyone's
gonna lit love them
one more lobster please thank you very
much here we go
for linguini two lobsters please get me
Rocco please
the result is delicious push to the
bottom and push it for linguini lobster
just for a change clean the place my
darling here we go
two-thirds of the diner's have order the
lobster linguine the starters have taken
an hour to leave the kitchen I spotted a
weakness here and it's not the food is
there nice it's rather loud it's really
good
the lobster is lovely nice as mine on to
the main course one two three follow
Phil it's our beef and once again Rocco
has failed to sell the two quicker
dishes on the main unit with cool
everyone's gone for the beef in it why
is he playing up that's one out guys
beef especially ones that well done it's
a tall order we're gonna be up to it
we're gonna be up to give me the huggy
threebees now
I just next give me some water is my
pressure test gonna bring Santino to his
knees I swear to God I feel like I'm
gonna faint
he's in the [ __ ] big-time and
I'm searching for my best Italian and
I'm putting Sicilian rest of Manila in
London's West End to the test with my
first challenge 30 customers have just
arrived and all ordered at the same time
front of house took orders for over 20
lobster linguine and almost thanked the
kitchen now head chef Santino has been
overwhelmed by the large number of
orders taken for the main course is
upsetting orders with all the linguine
on every check and more importantly it
will be all this beef three beef one
meeting one where when we fall down any
minute now I swear to God I feel like
I'm gonna faint
[Music]
give me some water
[Music]
right we're not gonna be late do you
understand me we are not going to be
late
[Music]
the rocker says he's held back the order
to help the kitchen catch up but what he
really means is they're even further
behind with the service than Santino
thought come on you got you have to have
the balls and explain the [ __ ] up you
can't hold a ticket but if you do hold a
ticket back he's got to know everything
instead than a main course what'd I just
do what will another one of the leading
ship I want this base we have a problem
we need to fix it let's go quickly I've
smoked medicine but the bottom line is
we forgot the ticket yeah didn't hold
anything back I forgot the [ __ ]
ticket and he's come here and he said of
being a man yeah and Tate said to me
with balls
look chef this happened yeah it can
happen to anyone he's come to me and
said to me and lied to me thinking I'm
stupid since tina's in the [ __ ] I mean
big time
all because of Rocco but I have to say
he's got my respect tonight because he's
encouraging those cooks
the answer the way we're nearly there
come on guys we could do this come on
boys believe it
um if that was Li in that situation ten
years ago I would have flipped my lid
big time and pickled the Bulls Arauco
turn them into [ __ ] blah blah 17
years cookies apart out tonight he's
only just made it to the end of service
but for my diners his simple Sicilian
food has been outstanding had the
lobster stock hopefully kept really nice
by the chili all right what was a menu
tonight the menu was linguine beef
linguine beef 25 times we had the
passion the soul of the food but we
didn't match it with a service when you
have a table of six I got to get that
six in and we waited 92 minutes before
you realized that that table was
forgotten that's not good enough
Rocco look back on it and learn that's
all you can do do it again and I'll kill
you all right look I want yeah well done
thank you
Thank You chef classy grazie
[Music]
I was so tense oh my god it was like the
biggest rush in your life it was just
amazing I don't know what went on with
her for hours I could kill him but we
held it together I got this stupid smile
on my face I'm so happy I'm so proud now
it's time for my second contender to be
put to the test it's such a wonderful
restaurant that my team and I felt it
simply had to be in the top two this is
Casimir in Bristol a fantastic Italian
restaurant now is run by two young
brothers who today are the youngest
holders of an issue star in Britain I've
got some very very high hopes for them
in this competition
I love this restaurant because it's a
family affair mum and dad front-of-house
and in the kitchen
two brothers creating cuisine unlike
anything I've ever seen in an Italian
restaurant really good presentation
unique brothers Peter and John Ray are
so creative and experimental that
frankly that make Heston look
old-fashioned
really want to take customers through a
new experience something special and
magical what I really like about these
two guys is their energy and their
ambition they are really seriously
pushing the colory boundaries out to the
extreme and they're still in their early
twenties you think exactly alike because
obviously it's two minds thinking on one
job we're almost like one complete
person if that makes sense
[Music]
you too I don't know if you're
completely bonkers or pair of child
geniuses
the bird gastronomic instinct which
can't be taught or learned I was proud
of my voice from the very first day that
were born the first step the first smile
but now what can I say is the proudest
father in the world
but I can see that this success has come
at a price
Peter and John raised culinary dreams
are being funded by every penny of their
parents life savings we have to
sacrifice our retirement
oh yeah basically yeah it was a big
gamble I tell you what's a big gamble
let's hope Packers paternal faith it's
going to be rewarded because Casimir are
about to face my first pressure test I'm
gonna hit them with 30 dinars all
arriving and ordering at the same time
the other station unlike Vanunu they've
just two hours to produce the perfect
meal for my special guests there's a lot
of anxiety in me I just want to get it
go in get the service site hopefully you
don't meet new mistakes today yeah is
about pressure
I'll be watching everything I'll be in
the kitchen I'll be in a dining room
I'll be missing nothing
you guys want a Michelin star last year
phenomenal today raise the bar again
my 30 guests are about to experience an
avant-garde take on Italian cuisine will
they love it or wish they've just gone
for a pizza
then let's go start going boys first out
chicken liver parfait face strong that
massive puree you want to be that strong
it's one of the main elements because
obviously that's where we highlight the
tops yes we're quite we like the hopes
and you just want the other faces work
around advice next up beetroot risotto
with pickled fennel 9 the table 7 how is
the resulting yeah very good and bravely
trout sous-vide the fish is vacuum
packed and cooked in a warm water bath
so it's texture remains unchanged it's
daring to experiment like this but you
can't alienate the customer they need to
understand what's being served to be
able to appreciate it
is this meant to be cooked like this
it's a bit more strange from systems it
is because this cooked over so it keeps
the texture paste I mean you can
probably ruin the customers are coming
here for the first time you have to
explain to them it has very pink very
very pink I do still do it stops the
confusion she'll miss challenged me on
what I was saying rather than just
accepting that I didn't like it and I
feel it wasn't cooked properly which
then made it very hard for me to send it
back it's crucial to keep customers on
side a mum susan has to take
responsibility for that front of house
we're not in the 1980s and if a
customer's there fish cooked a little
bit more two seconds two minutes
whatever it may be
you get it done next up quail with
celery root puree on a pastry nest it's
also sir very rare and again customers
should be told
when we asked how the Equator was kept
by which she's been around and said what
cost something you have to get used to
I didn't really I didn't really
appreciate that too much
I'm worried by how much food is coming
back uneaten just one thing that strikes
me know I'm technically back the kitchen
just dumped here no one gives these guys
[Music]
find out how your motherly love is a
wonderful thing but keeping the truth
from your chefs is a mistake did you
ever get feedback from the dining room
absolutely yeah yeah
when pretty much our base night most
nights yes and what kind of feedback do
get back pizza and jelly I'm normally
really positive ever since
nobody was really perfect pretty smooth
I get complaints in my Russian that's
the only way I've learned because you
constantly get feedback on a daily basis
not always great and blow smoke up each
other's ass you only learn from
negatives not the positives
Peter and John Ray have finished service
in less than two hours and despite some
criticisms most of my guests love
Casimir I thought the food was really
special really spectacular for the
dishes were really intricate and really
clever and really well-balanced - really
really good you wouldn't go to many
other places to get this overcooking in
these sort of ideas on your plate and
the presentation is fantastic in a
Michelin star doesn't confirm everything
you said now it's perfect if you're
trying to be avant-garde you've got to
go with your customers you've got to
take every customer forward and like I
said if she wants her fish cooked more I
cook it I cook her trout more and if
anything comes back that's half eaten
these - what they need to know is what's
wrong with it there and then not at the
end of the night not 15 minutes later
you're missing you're missing my point
no all I want in my restaurant on a
daily basis is the negatives that makes
me better and they're your chefs
not your sons they're your sons on your
day off this family depends on this
restaurant and it's a business it's not
a playground there's a big difference
there is a big difference well done
thanks quarter though
[Music]
it's difficult when you've got family
working together obviously between
nothing that I've run in front of house
like Gordon said wrapping and wrapping
us in cotton was absolutely everything
he says to you true there's two very
talented young Chefs in there what they
need now is that level of guidance but
tough love and not having their ass kiss
by their mother
[Music]
tonight - brilliant restaurants are
battling to become my best Italian and
win a place in the semi-final the coach
trip pushed them both of the limits now
I've invited to London for debrief what
they don't know is since they last saw
me
I've sent secret diners into the
restaurant to see how they perform when
they're not in the spotlight and their
guard is down secret diners are
invaluable they'll catch any restaurant
off guard and I use them on a weekly
basis
[Music]
food critic Simon Davies is one of the
best in the business and has judged food
and service at thousands of restaurants
Sarah Darren Robinson has worked with me
another top chefs for years creating and
perfecting thousands of dishes it's one
thing serving easy to please customers
but how will my competitors perform when
my undercover diners are deliberately
difficult and demanding
I'm allergic to those I can't eat
sultanas first to face the music is
Sicilian restaurant Manila what I need
to tell you now you've actually been
tested twice I sent in a secret diner
the coach trip identified front of house
as manila's weak point will Sara find
that manager Angelo has improved things
since my last visit ten minutes before
even a menu a drink bread
Oliver is too long come on ten minutes
ten bloody minis ten goddamn minutes
wait yes that's it sometimes that's all
what would you recommend in your
antipasti
yes
[Music]
otherwise in the book the front end is a
chickpea features we connect in truffles
[Music]
favorite and then he just pointed
everything in red said on the menu which
is what I've been doing over the last 10
minutes
a lady ones your personal recommendation
she's not asking to read the menu our
game she's asking for this is delicious
but I've just tasted his it's absolutely
fantastic can I can I change and have
that it's there for yes inaudible do you
mind
okay thank you
prego what's going on prego what's going
look at your face
he's just so delicious I wanted that one
instead
[Music]
yeah yeah I don't want this it's great I
wanted to have them the beaver for the
charge yeah that's absolutely fine of
course yeah no no that's fine yeah thank
you
[Music]
yeah it's good it's good thank you
Wow was a disaster
have you any idea how flexible we have
to be with customers today I
deliberately put her in there to see
what level of flexibility your
restaurant gracious really really
gracious well you coming out and being
ten times more charming than your maitre
d perfect immaculate fantastic squared I
have an absolutely delicious
service that's letting it them it's not
doing justice to what's coming out of
country and so talk to me please
I remember I say very well today was a
crazy lunch yeah I agree with you that
many thing were wrong did they fought
earlier and it's not always like that
follow me now that was a bad day we will
have them bounce back and put it right
you're more capable of doing it
there's a bet the first thing to do I
mean where people coming in looking from
where man you give the drink it's not
the same any officer 10 minutes or so be
a little bit so long I mean a little bit
it's too long it's too long so I don't
think anyway I'm not gonna sugarcoat say
it's not a good thing no or definitely
come back from it and you know we're a
restaurant we're a live thing we you
know we're growing all the time we've
only just got there and we're doing
amazing amazing work every day every
service we're doing a great job and
that's why we're still in this and we
can win this before the truck was
slightly on the good next the team from
Casa Mia faced the truth of my
undercover diner it's about taste isn't
it
excuse me you're now gonna undermine a
customer
tonight two brilliant restaurants are
battling out to become my best Italian
and win a place in the semi-final of my
nationwide retro competition now it's
Bristol restaurant kazimierz turn to
discover that I've been spying on them
[Music]
you've had one huge challenge so far in
this competition and unknown to all four
of you there's actually been - Tess yeah
because no one spotting the second one
that they where the first one was the
face well water well you came and the
second one is huh after I left the
restaurant I sent my secret diner to
your restaurant mm-hmm and this is what
you saw sorry we've got to valid charge
Thank You Simon my undercover critic is
having the trout which some of my 30
diners left uneaten and also the peas I
thought the trout was slightly
undercooked I thought and the peas peas
could have done with another minute on
the Brahma is about taste but they were
undercooked
yeah there is no debate about damn it's
about taste isn't it
excuse me you're now gonna undermine my
customer she's got to take criticism
seriously that's cold
excuse me
cause god yes a bit cold this do you
know she's a bit taller than us and I'm
afraid because it plates the place of it
[Applause]
the cold he was a bit like a headmaster
then if your children the kitchen of
you're working with families it's often
very hard to be objective about their
mistakes and their errors mum and dad as
always
overprotective as parents you're not
dropping them off to school anymore the
customers King they're the ones parting
with the 55 crates over 10 courses the
other ones that want to boast of their
friends on the way back about coming to
this amazing amazing restaurant you have
to act a little bit more humble flowers
thank you the push and the finale
in essence I'll say this is a very good
very strong trying to do excellent
things
and sometimes it's little bit misjudged
perhaps think about doing tasting menu
it doesn't have ten dishes which is our
six dishes which are fabulous the place
has the most amazing potential yeah
customer feedback is crucial what you've
got to do is just listen the customers
loved by us by our customers yes I know
I'm not a complain we have to we have to
have a plan how we answer to the
customer
Gordon say we three I treat them with
cotton water but perhaps is being a
father but yes we I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to be a little bit tougher and put
my point of view across much in a bunch
tough away after injuring my coach later
diners and the undercover team I sent in
both Manila and Casimir have survived
bloodied but unbowed now it's time for
the final test as the chef's leave their
restaurants and their front-of-house
teams behind and go it alone in my
kitchen I've asked them to create a dish
worthy of a place on the menu at my
three Michelin star restaurant it's been
an incredible journey for both these
amazing Italian restaurants serious
contenders in this competition and all
very talented chefs today I'm gonna
eliminate one of them from the
competition
both chefs will cook just one course but
it'll be the most important dish of
their lives
[Music]
it's their final chance to prove
themselves gonna prove what we believe
in you know the last year has been a
roller coaster ride for me and for
Giacomo as well it's actually opening
mendler then darkness hit us both he
lost his father I lost my brother this
is for them and for us yeah yeah of
Amendola sorry but we want our food to
be in that pitiful three-star restaurant
a lot of anxiety enough I should want to
get it right as well I think we'll get
everything perfect everything just needs
to be much yeah we realized if you're
foolish to have a reach Freestar status
today that needs to have that edge
but it's not just me they have to
impress I've invited 20 highly
distinguished guests including Carlos
present' a director of the Italian
Cultural Institute and Anna del conte
one of the most respected Italian food
writers in Britain these discerning
diners will be served both competing
dishes and every plate must be perfect
right gentlemen today's the day one of
you will be going through to the
semi-final and sadly one of you will not
be cooking again in this competition you
now have got the perfect platform to
show off every plate is crucial it
starts now good luck
for the chef's there is nowhere to hide
they'll be judged purely on the quality
of their food
I've challenged them to create one dish
using a classic Italian ingredient veal
and I can't wait to see what they do
with
okay first to go on in Manila for Vail
please yes chef
up until now something has been let down
by his front of house but his cooking's
been flawless tonight he's designed a
dish true to Sicilian roots fill it a
veal served with summer truffles layered
potatoes G roll mushrooms and a cream of
celeriac I'm gonna keep it really simple
I'm fried the veal and we're gonna serve
it with a little potato cake which has
been done with a shoulder revealed then
pop roasted raised right six hours
really slow what's the sauce the sauce
is gonna be a little reduction on my
cellar wine but you got lots of
earthiness on the dish so I wanted to
give it an element of sweetness like I
could I've been dipping chutney all
right this is classic Santino he's
created a robust dish with few
ingredients happy four layered cake with
a braised veal delicious like a braised
oxtail it's a real sort of party but
amazing dish mushrooms will Forge our
old potato before draggable Santino's
now gotta focus he's passion and energy
into making this a winning dish this is
absolutely everything to me there's a
lot riding on this only time NW
liquidoff okay a little bit more liquid
there that veil where the truffle is
delicious but their cooking is you're
all the most amazing mushrooms and
Jackie was not even seasoning there's
only four things on the plate and they
have to be done perfectly and if this
mushrooms are under seasoned it just
destroys the whole dish he's totally
innocent people once you've got to taste
Giacomo yeah
everything and that's really amazing
zero yeah
peeled my hands yeah so take pretty lean
and no salt on there juggle juggle relax
yeah
use her head yeah his sous-chefs let him
down
but Santino's remain calm and
impressively focused
thank you fantastic Thank You chef
[Music]
it's like I gave you the juggle mop the
potato papers go just got lots of flavor
it's a beautiful dish
they taste amazing customer fall comes
away table 6-4 caponata please I was
worried the castamere boys might risk
you all with something dangerously
experimental but I can see it changing
them their vill caponata service
sweetbreads has all the hallmarks of a
classic Italian dish but knowing these
boys there is something more to it you
wouldn't do this without a twist
somewhere yeah where's a liquid nitrogen
it's a classic dish this has really been
refined so lie again precise temperature
with readings from the water bath with
the sweetbreads and the milk they were a
very refined class and you got that
Shafi'i part with the veal sweetbreads
how you cooking that we've put some in a
water bath we have a charm is 62 for two
hours deep oh yes a nice crust there
should be this remote in your Maximus
you see those we've made sure when you
cook them they killed in the center as
well yeah some of my coach diners found
Peter and John raise fish and quail to
experimental I hope they've picked the
sweetbreads right for my diner's tonight
service please
caponata there
delicious
[Music]
but with everything to play for the boys
are starting to panic in my kitchen
they're out there compass own and it's
showing do me a favor don't slice that
veal and she was thirty seconds away
from completing that dish when you slice
the veal what happens to it starts to
get cold I said yeah but what comes out
of it our juices so we want those juices
wedding in on that wait was that
national flavor I'll you've just passed
your balls to do four stunning dishes a
slice at the very last minute yeah dr.
Yeoh olive oil nachos let's go you can't
slice the veal when you five minutes
away from completing the dish who on
that slice when you're seconds away from
that final magic on that plate so they
get rid of those now relax compose and
step up to the plate quickly I know
you're used to your mum wiping your ass
but I'm not gonna clear down after you
guys yet no [ __ ] way
am i clear down after you in my own
kitchen yes no chef every time we set up
with this yeah we caraway guys yes chef
that's more we my kitchen and I'm so
boring yours - I'm not clearing the
[ __ ] mess
this as a musician is sensational
don't worry that's those hot yes a
little bit hotter with your water bar
be careful you don't scold yourself I'll
get your mom on my back just a mere last
table
yeah well that last table going out in
secular the first level so is please go
nice aesthetic Walker good job
slow start strong finish ah don't play
down service is over and we dine as we
serve both restaurants dishes and are
about to discover my distinguished
guests thought of them starting with
kazimierz the sweet blue absolutely fill
it for me was so fun I prefer the
Casimir dish the single element were
better and that they mix also was right
there for me nice to see how was it I
look at that dish I can see the boys
soul that brought tears to my eyes now
call me Baez
but I definitely prefer the cannula dish
the meat was very well cooked and I like
the combination of meat and truffle very
well done
what we did was like hitman things your
marks it was very sweet my diners
comments have confirmed the level of
excellence in this competition now it's
up to me to choose a winner whatever I
decide will affect the future of both
these restaurants and their chefs I'm
still very very simple a favor the hits
home that's what I do that's why I stand
by what I change what I am I think we've
done enough fun you know I mean we've
sent our dishes in time in when we
communicated we play here deaf it's
cooked perfectly
we're in a 2d different environments
wherever used to for love they're
absolutely only one of these two
brilliant Italian restaurants can go
through to the semi-finals it's a very
tough decision but one I've got to make
my two top Italian restaurants Manila
from London in Kasimir from Bristol have
finished their final challenge and for
one of them that journey is about to
come to an end they've both proved
themselves exceptional restaurants but
now it all hangs in the balance it's
time for me to taste the amazing dishes
cooked here tonight by Santino and the
kastle-meyer brothers Peter and John ray
after which I'll make my final decision
Luis looks great and a nice clever use
of seasoned ingredients the G rolls
summer truffles that's delicious
it's got such great finesse but very
bold flavors really good I absolutely
love the puree it looks quite rich but
it actually tastes quite healthy really
nice if we rot one criticism it's a
braised shoulder it's almost like
braised oxtails very rich and I sort of
overpowers the potatoes Casa Mia
it looks dainty sweetbreads very
dangerous to serve in any restaurant hmm
nice combination of flavor it's fragrant
that buzzer the end just really helps to
lift it clever
I've got a problem with the rawness of
the courgettes because it's sort of
sports textures however the meats cooked
perfectly ricotta works bloody
brilliantly with the sweetbreads the big
surprise for me today is that both these
dishes taste better than I tasted in
their restaurants
[Music]
so it's the moment of truth
- outstanding Italian restaurants but
only one can win a place in the
semi-final
[Music]
okay first off well done the magic and
the personalities coming through on
those plates today was fabulous Casimir
whatever happens after this competition
continue cooking food like that there
are cotta and the sweetbreads and the
Philip packed full of flavor elegant and
that worked criticizing the dish a lot
going on there a hell of a lot going on
the textures were amazing but you call
jets what you crunchy
Manila there's a huge heart in what you
do and you are one focused guy love what
you did with the Slayer Puri generous
with the truffles that's you how could I
criticize the dish of what my shoulder
was quite heavy but packed full of
flavor
[Music]
but this competition is not gonna be won
or lost on one dish alone it'll be down
to this which restaurant would I love to
return to and eat one more meal Casimir
Manila you guys and your restaurants
have been under immense pressure think
back to that Coach load of diners
walking in there 30 of them sitting down
it's a nightmare for any restaurant
you've been under scrutiny with secret
diners filming undercover I think both
restaurants took the criticism admirably
I think you're really handled not just
the positives but the negatives as well
and that's what I love to see how you
bounce back
sadly there going to be one restaurant
going through to the semi-final
based on everything I've seen taste it
and being part of
the restaurant that's going through to
the semi-final
[Music]
custom ear
great job absolutely brilliant
[Music]
Marilla you are a man that is on a
mission when your team is as good as you
you're gonna pop big-time in a great
experience we said before we came in on
no matter what happened you'd be we'd be
happy I like to win but that's that's
just a game
congratulations really job well done
didn't expect it I think you know we
didn't have such a tough call because we
work our nuts off a lot and assignment
now you have to have obviously approval
from the Gordon to the next round it's
just unbelievable in that my mom and dad
and sucker it hurts but I yeah and
they've sacrificed everything I know I
[Music]
know you know mum down a sacrifice
everything over the last ten years and
as long as everybody sticks together
think we'll keep going fire you know I
think we're just gonna go to that next
semi-finals and know that we can
actually move forward and get through to
the final and hopefully go on to win the
things I've lost Manila that's a big
voice and a heavyweight in this contest
but I have found Casimir two young guys
that mean business and now it's game on